today we're talking about vm manager
bare metal solutions
and cloud sql insights i'm roger
martinez and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
we've just announced vm manager a suite
of infrastructure management tools
designed to simplify and automate the
maintenance of large fleets of compute
engine vms
this cloud native solution has google
scale infrastructure in mind
providing a simplified tool set for
automated compliance reporting
and software deployment at scale check
out the blog to learn more
google is committed to being a leader in
open cloud
part of that commitment is bare metal
solution which enables developers to run
oracle database workloads on google
cloud
and now we're announcing three
enhancements availability in our 10th
region montreal
a new smaller a-core server and support
for pci dss and hipaa
to learn more and see it in action head
over to the blog
cloud sql insights is a simple open tool
that helps developers quickly understand
and resolve database performance issues
on cloud sql allowing your database
analysts to focus on more strategic
tasks
even more helpful we've made insights
for the previous seven days available to
everyone
at no additional cost those metrics will
be displayed in the dashboard so check
them out for yourself
we've just announced the general
availability of dialog flow cx
part of google cloud's contact center ai
solution which includes a brand new set
of capabilities for advanced virtual
agents
with this virtual agent technology your
contact center agents can focus on the
highest priority customer interactions
while your virtual agents hold down the
fort handling routine calls
check it out today if you want to read
more about these announcements
or see a full list check out the link
any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud
you